roissy en brie en région parisienne
marie france bergougnoux va rejoindre
son poste de travail tout simplement
dans le salon de son pavillon
années 80 voici les débuts du
télétravail en france à l'époque
l'informatique commence à se généraliser
dans les entreprises françaises
quelques employeurs et salariés
expérimental or le travail à distance en
ce directeur des ptt y croyait dur comme
fer ce qu'ils ne formulent de travail
qui devrait se développer parce que à
mon avis le correspond à la tante d'une
grande partie de personnel moins de
transport plus de flexibilité c'était
les travailleuses n'y voyait aussi que
des avantages
ma foi le mercredi je peu décalé mais
horaire puisque c'est la journée des
enfants
et puis même en semaine
même en semaine normale quoi le lundi ou
le mardi je peux très bien décalé mais
aura aussi mais ces nouvelles conditions
de travail suscite aussi quelques
inquiétudes
l'isolément du salarié en faisait partie
selon cet expert
et on sait très bien que plus d'une
personne est isolée puis les personnes
seules et des plus le risque de devenir
oser plus elle est angoissée plus elle a
progressivement un peu peur de tout
pourtant pour le gouvernement le
télétravail a de l'avenir en france en
1993 les ministres de l'aménagement du
territoire et de l'économie commandes
d'un rapport sur le sujet au chef
d'entreprise thierry breton donc ils
m'ont demandé l'un et l'autre j'en passe
quoi parce que justement ça concerne
l'aménagement du territoire et on
comprend bien qu'on peut redistribuer
l'activité sur le territoire grâce au
télétravail et al ahmad là parce que ça
concerne en priorité la compétitivité
une nouvelle organisation du travail qui
affecte donc les entreprises et dans
certaines circonstances les télétravail
s'impose même comme une solution
évidente exemple pendant les grèves des
transports de 1995
cette grève n'a pas trop perturbé le
travail des 90 salariés de l'entreprise
certains 2 chez eux ont pu travailler
comme s'il était dans la société
avec l'aide des nouvelles technologies
de communication dans les années 2000
pour mieux encadrer le télétravail
plusieurs lois et accords
interprofessionnels sont signés mais la
pratique a du mal à se généraliser en
2011 par exemple il y avait à peine 9%
de télétravailleurs en france contre 19%
en allemagne et plus de 30% aux
etats-unis en belgique ou en suède
une réalité qui expliquait alors ce
spécialiste je pense qu'il ya cela est
lié à des frênes culturelles notamment
dans l'organisation hiérarchique des
entreprises d'aujourd'hui mais je n'ai
aucun doute le télétravail se
développera en france aussi aujourd'hui
le télétravail séduit effectivement de
plus en plus les entreprises et les
travailleurs français en 2010 8 29% des
salariés y avait eu recours soit 20
points de plus qu'en 2011
et ces derniers mois à l'épreuve des
grèves et du coronavirus la pratique a
largement été sollicités
[Musique]